welcome to the playlist on statistic
something I've been meaning to do for
some time so anyway I just want to get
right into the meat of it and I'll try
to do as many examples as possible and
hopefully give you the feel for what
statistics is all about and really just
to kind of start off in case you're not
familiar that although I think a lot of
people have an intuitive feel for what
statistics is about statistics it
essentially well actually maybe I should
well in very general terms its kind of
getting your head around data and it can
broadly be classified well there may be
three categories you know you have
descriptive so say you have a lot of
data and you wanted to tell someone
about it without giving them all of the
data maybe you can kind of find
indicative numbers that somehow
represent all of that data without
having to go over all the data so that
would be descriptive statistics there's
also predictive well I'll kind of group
them together there's inferential
statistics inferential and this is when
you use data to essentially make
conclusions about things so let's say
you've sampled some data from a
population and we'll talk a lot about
samples versus populations but I think
you have just a basic sense of what that
is right like if I survey three people
who are going to vote for president I
clearly haven't surveyed the entire
population I've surveyed a sample but
what inferential statistics are all
about are if we can do some math on the
samples maybe we can make inferences or
conclusions about the population as a
whole
well anyway that's just a big picture of
what statistics is all about so let's
just get into the meat of it and we'll
start we'll start with the descriptive
the descriptive so the first thing that
I don't know that I would want to do or
I think most people would want to do
when they are when they're given a whole
set of numbers and they're told to
describe it is that well maybe I can
come up with some number that is most
indicative of all of the numbers in that
set so or some number that represents
kind of the central tendency this is a
word you'll see a lot in statistics
books the central tendency of a set of
numbers central tendency cent tendency
and this is also called the average and
I'll be a little bit more exact here
than I normally am with the word average
when I talk about it in this context it
just means that the average is a number
that somehow is giving us a sense of the
central tendency or maybe a number that
is most representative of a set and I
know that sounds all very abstract but
let's do a couple of examples so there's
a bunch of ways that you can actually
measure the central tendency or the
average of a set of numbers and you've
probably seen these before they are the
mean
actually there's types of means but
we'll stick with the arithmetic mean or
if motika and we talk about stock
returns and things will do geometric
means and and maybe we'll cover the
harmonic mean one day there's a mean the
median median and the mode and the
statistics peak these are all these all
can kind of be representative of a data
sets or population central tendency or a
sample central tendency and there they
all are collectively they can all be
forms of an average and I think when we
see examples it'll make a little bit
more sense in everyday speak when people
talk about an average and I think you've
already computed averages in your life
they're usually talking about the
arithmetic mean so normally when someone
says let's take the average of these
numbers and they expect you to do
something they want you to figure out
the arithmetic mean they don't want you
to figure out the median or the mode but
before we go any further let's let's
figure out what these things are so let
me let me make up a a set of numbers
let's say I have the number 1 let's say
I have another one to have a 2 a 3 let's
say I have Oh
4 I don't know that's good enough
we just want a simple example so the
mean or the arithmetic mean is probably
what you're most familiar with and when
people talk about average and that's
essentially you add up all the numbers
and you divide by the numbers that there
are so this would in this case it would
be 1 plus 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 and
you're going to divide by 1 2 3 4 5
numbers and this is what 1 plus 1 is 2 2
plus 2 is 4 4 plus 3
seven 7 plus 4 is 11 so this is equal to
11 over five that's what that's 2 and
1/5 so that's equal to 2 point 2 and so
someone could say hey you know that is a
pretty good representative number of
this set all of that's the number that
all of these numbers you can kind of say
are closest to or 2.2 represents the
central tendency of this set and in
common speak that would be the average
but if we're being a little bit more
particular this is the arithmetic mean
of this set of numbers and you see it
kind of represents them if I didn't if I
didn't want to give you the list of five
numbers I could say well you know I have
a set of five numbers and their mean is
2.2 and it kind of tells you a little
bit of at least you know where the
numbers are right and we'll talk a
little bit more about how do you how do
you know how far the numbers are from
that I mean in in probably the next
video so that's one measure another
measure instead of averaging it in this
way you can average it by putting the
numbers in order which I actually
already did so let's put them let's just
write them down and order again 1 1 2 3
4 and you just take the middle number so
let's see there's 1 2 3 4 5 number so
the middle number is going to be right
here right the middle number is 2
there's two numbers greater than 2 and
there's two numbers less than 2 and this
is called the median so it's it's
actually very little computation you
just have to essentially sort the
numbers and then you find whatever
number where you have an equal number
greater than or less than that number so
the median of this set is 2 and you see
I mean that's actually fairly close to
the mean and there's no right answer one
of these isn't a better answer for the
average they're just different ways of
measuring the average so here it's the
median and I know what you might be
thinking well that was easy enough when
we had five numbers what if we had six
numbers what if what if it was like this
what if what if this was our set of
numbers 1 1 2 3 let's add another 4
there so now there's no middle number
right I mean you know 2 is not the
middle number because there's 2 less
than 3 larger than it and then 3 is not
the middle number because there's 3
larger and sorry there's 2 larger and
three smaller than it so there's no
middle number so when you have a set
with even numbers and someone tells you
to figure out the median what you do is
you take the middle two numbers
you take the middle two numbers and then
you take the arithmetic mean of those
two numbers so in this case of this set
the median would be 2.5 fair enough but
let's put this aside because I want to
compare the median and the means and the
modes for the same set of numbers but
that's that's a good thing to know
because sometimes it can be a little
confusing and you know there's nothing
these are all definitions these are all
kind of mathematical tools for getting
our heads around numbers there's nothing
you know it's not like some one day
someone saw one of these formulas on
like the face of the Sun and says oh
that's part of the universe that this is
how the average should be calculated
these are human constructs to kind of
just get our our heads around large sets
of data I mean this isn't a large set of
data but instead of five numbers if we
had 5 million numbers you could imagine
that you don't like thinking about every
number individually anyway before I talk
more about that let me tell you what the
mode is and the mode to some degree it's
the one that I think most people
probably forget or never learn and when
they see it on an exam it confuses them
because they're like oh that sounds very
advanced but in some ways it is the
easiest of all of the measures of
central tendency or of average the mode
is essentially what number is most
common in a set so in this example
there's two ones and then there's one of
everything else right so the mode here
is one so mode you kind of say is the
most common number and then you could
kind of say well hey Sal what if what if
this was our set 1 1 2 3 4 4 here I have
two ones and I have two fours and this
is where the mode gets a little bit
tricky because either of these would
have been a decent answer for the mode
you could have actually said the motive
this is 1 or the mode of this is 4 and
it gets a little bit ambiguous and you
probably want a little clarity from the
person asking you most times on a test
when they ask you there's not going to
be the same thing you do there will be a
most common number in the set so now
you're saying well you know why did why
wasn't just one of these good enough you
know why we learned averages why don't
we just use averages or why don't we use
arithmetic mean all the time what's the
median and mode good for well I'll try
to do a little one example of that and
see if it if it rings true with you and
then you could think a little bit more
let's say I had this set of No
verse three three three three three
and I don't know and 100 so what's the
arithmetic mean here what's the mean
here they have one two three four five
threes and a hundred so it would be 115
divided by six right all right cuz I
have one two three four five six numbers
115 is just the sum of all of these so
that's equal to how many times does 6 go
into 115 six 115 to six goes into it one
time one times six is six fifty five
goes into nine times 9 times 6 is 54 so
it's equal to 19 and one-sixth fair
enough I just added all the numbers and
divide by how many there are and but but
my question is is this really
representative of this set I mean I have
a ton of threes and then I have a
hundred all of a sudden and we're saying
that the central tendency is 19 and one
six and I mean 99 one six doesn't really
seem indicative of this set I mean maybe
it does depending on your application
but it just seems a little bit off right
I mean my intuition would be that the
central tendency is something closer to
three because there's a lot of threes
here so what would what would the median
tell us the median well I already put
these numbers in order right if I giving
you out of order you'd want to put in
this order and you say what's the middle
number let's see the middle two numbers
tend to have an even number are 3 & 3 so
if I take the average of 3 & 3 or if
fashion should be particular with my
language if I take the arithmetic mean
of 3 & 3 I get 3 and this is maybe a
better a better measurement of the
central tendency or of the average of
this of this set of numbers right
essentially what it does is by taking
the median I wasn't so much affected by
this really large number that's very
different than the others and statistics
they call that an outlier a number that
you know if you talked about average
home prices maybe every house in the
city is a hundred thousand dollars and
then there's one house that costs a
trillion dollars and then if someone
told you the average house price was I
don't know a million dollars you might
have a very wrong perception of that
city but the median house price the
median house price would be a hundred
thousand dollars and you'd get a better
sense of what the houses in that city
like so similarly this median maybe it
gives you a better sense of what the
numbers in this set are like right
because the at the arithmetic mean was
skewed by this with you know what do
they call an outlier and and being able
to tell what an outlier is it's kind of
one of those things that a statistician
will say well I know it when I see it
there isn't really a formal definition
for it but it tends to be a number that
really kind of sticks out and sometimes
it's due to you know a measurement error
or whatever and then finally the mode
what is the most common number in the
set well there's three there's five
threes and there's 100 so the most
common number is once again it's a three
so in this case when you had this
outlier the meet in the mode tend to be
you know maybe they're a little bit
better about giving you an indication of
what this of what these numbers
represent maybe this was just a
measurement error but I don't know we
don't actually know what these represent
if these are our house prices and I
would say I would argue that these are
probably more indicative measures of
what the houses in an area you know cost
but if this is something else that this
is scores on a test maybe you know maybe
there is one kid in the class one out of
six kids who did really really well and
everyone else didn't study and this is
more indicative of kind of how students
at that level do on average anyway I'm
done talking about all of this in the
and and I encourage you to play with a
lot of numbers and and and deal with the
concepts yourself in the next video
we'll explore more descriptive
statistics instead of talking about the
central tendency we'll talk about how
spread apart things are away from the
central tendency see in the next video